Nhóm kênh nhà khoa tu đại học, mà hà sinh ra khăn của Thailand, phối hợp với University College
lần đồn vường quốc anh, và công bố phát hiện loại khủng lắm mới.
Măng tên, năng ca tì tên Chai Avo Mises. Đưa ra đình là loại lớn nhất từ giận tại Thailand và khu vực đồng
là máy. Hoá thách được khai quả tại tình Chai Avo M Đông Bắc Thailand, và công bố Chin tạp
chỉ sân chifik report, thời gian nghiên cứu loại này thủ hỏi trên Ngo SuryD, nhóm khủng lắm
cao có cầu và đôi dài, bây chủ dài ước tình, hai người bẩy điểm mà mi mấy và trong lượng hơn 20 tấn,
tương đường khoảng chiến con vào choa chừng thành một số xong hoa thách cho thấy xong đùi dài hơn hai mấy.
Cái nhau khoảng cho biết, nè gà tì tên Chai Avo Mises, sinh sống cách đây khoảng 1 chăm để 1 chăm 2 mi trụ năng,
trong kỳ vẫn trắng, sấm hơn khoảng 1 mi trụ năng sau 1 mi trụ rice,
trường nhau mình cứu cho biết đây là chí tràn của iku một người thay lần, sau hóa thách được tình thầy trong lớp đá chảy nhất,
còn lương giữ giống tế khủng lắm tại khu vực.
Và điện này được đánh giá là có phần làm gió thêm lịch sự tiện hoa sinh học của chế đất.